calm and then what I maintain that's
that really depends on who's choking you
cuz Josh Burkman choked him completely
unconscious okay okay yeah yeah you know
Berkman's got a hell of a guillotine and
John Fitch shot in on them and Berkman
caught him in the guillotine you just
brought sleep in the first round well I
think if there's there's guys they can
just put you to sleep right I can if you
think that you can get away with that
[ __ ] with like a marcelo garcia you're
gonna wake up going what happened
okay yeah okay but most guys won't be
able to choke you sits at that point you
know and again i'm catching up on 157
days if UFC you know why i was actually
out at sea with the McGregor and khabib
but on that note do you think he tapped
premature do you think though you had to
sleep mcgregor went to sleep
oh that in that fight oh you met john
fishes Josh Berg
yeah no no net crank right no he did not
tap premature um he did not defend it
though okay here's the deal he was done
he was beaten down could be [ __ ] him
up could be be smashed him but there was
a lot of people that don't train and
this was very frustrating to me there's
many people that don't train that think
that that was something that you
shouldn't tap to they're they're out of
their [ __ ] mind
okay that is what's called a fulcrum Cho
that's okay okay it's it's not
necessarily a choke but it is it chokes
you but it really feels like your
[ __ ] heads gonna pop off right what
he's doing is he's wrapping around the
face and you don't have to even go under
the jaw you can get it on the chin
especially if you're as strong as Kebede
then you clamp your hands together and
you're pressing your forearm against his
back so you've got this and you get the
forum against his back and you're doing
this just leave this [ __ ] head it's
just like hits and khabib is so strong
his gray he's been grappling since he
was a baby right all of his muscles are
designed to squeeze and crush and smash
and he gets a hold of your neck in that
position and he's got that forearm
pressed against your back see if he can
find an image of the actual submission
you could really clearly see what he's
doing and then there was a video where
Dean Lister and my friend Hans Mullen
camp
scribed it's pulling that up and it's
been taken off that video yeah the Hans
mollenkamp Dean Lister video so long
maybe someone reposted it and that link
is gone but yeah huh
um did you check gene Lister's that's so
weird
wonder why anybody would take that down
um anyway mizuka [ __ ] your face up
without even going under the neck a good
example here's another good example just
pull this up you got it okay one from
right after the fight but he's still
describing it okay oh this is perfect
this is perfect so Dean Lister who's a a
world champion Brazilian jiu-jitsu
blackbelt as legit as it gets and this
is my friend Hans Mullen camp
he's also brazilian jiu-jitsu black belt
and see see this is exactly what khabib
did see how his forearm is pressed
against the back and the arm is under
the chin see the difference is what Dean
is doing he can't even help himself he's
immediately putting his arms his hands
on the arm that's choking him that's
what you're supposed to do now if you
look at what Connor did Connor just
waited until he couldn't take it anymore
intact right right when you see Connor
both of his arms are down he's getting
his neck cranked and he doesn't do this
right that's what you're supposed to do
you supposed to do two on one and then
you drop down like look at this see what
he's doing there he's tapping
let's see where his left arm is okay
yeah that left arm should not there's
you you can't you can't do that see that
is a perfect example of the fulcrum
choke see how he's doing that pressing
his forearm against the back squeezing
the head it's it's a neck crank it's a
choke there's a lot of [ __ ] going on
there it doesn't have to be under the
chin it could just be on your face and
you're gonna get [ __ ] up
so all those folks out there that were
saying that it wasn't a choke need to go
have someone apply that to them and they
need to start training jiu-jitsu and
stop [ __ ] talking about MMA
submissions because they don't write
that you're gonna tap [ __ ] don't say
you're not gonna tap you get a [ __ ]
tap right I know everybody's gonna tap
from that because other people unlike
Connor are gonna be better at defending
that thinking a great like you get a
hold of world-class Brazilian jiu-jitsu
blackbelt who's also an MMA fighter like
like Vinny Magalhaes he's gonna grab
ahold of that he's gonna defend properly
he's gonna adjust he's gonna try to get
out of that yeah yeah he might have to
tap if someone gets him in it I mean he
people tap but he's he's not gonna just
have one arm posted that's just not the
right way to handle but I think that's
because Connor had eaten bombs